what is happy to reject Nations Greg out
here its Andrew here so after two months
of binging flash and arrow so I can be
prepared for a comic-con I have finished
both shows as of yesterday okay there
yeah well done I need to catch up on
arrow what flash you're caught up on
season three I thought it was okay I
like the first two seasons more but a
little repetitive not as intense as the
first two have been but now it's flash
and I love the characters and everything
I enjoyed the season I'd say I kind of
harp anyway you said I just seeing a
speedster for the third time even though
it was an interesting plot twist that I
kind of guess what was going to happen
but still I yeah it was it was
definitely a little bit interesting but
again seeing a speedster for the third
time around kylo repetitive as you
mentioned I'm really looking forward to
seeing in season four of them not going
with a speedster and they're going with
someone else so it's going to be
delighted to see and obviously they kind
of mentioned in season three they gave
us Easter eggs but saying clipper de
veau who is the thinker so it's going to
be really interesting if this might be
taken on the flash reborn we'll see I
mean that'd be interesting I mean that's
an interesting storyline obviously they
did flashpoint paradox in for one
episode and did three but it's going to
be interesting to see what we see in
this rig in this video let's get to it
do its run Barry run
like that logo here we go here we go
it was the like majesty
my name is iris West will you marry me
and I was supposed to marry status in
life loving to brother for me I promise
to run
[Music]
yeah she's hot
[Music]
could you possibly be further we made
you curled in a ball and cry all day
sometimes I feel like if I believe that
something hard enough that'll make it
real let's go in this I'm sorry he's not
coming back
you don't know that Barry Tony to be
shown to be strong
[Music]
I understand this should've worked
dead-bang sorry
[Music]
you're up against in that hombre we
think they do go cut with a sword flash
where's your city Falls how cancer is
that if we're not from the flash people
looking at diamonds gonna be honest I
made a few slight modifications as
Captain solo would say I resumed all
people have you not be
[Music]
Wow did you bury in the trailer I like
that awesome here I love to escape that
way it basically represents us
comic-book geeks and then monopoly yeah
yeah is awesome he's awesome that I love
it the truth didn't show Barry in it
because of the way how the last season
ended it's like obviously Barry's gonna
come back called flash it's still I get
you hyped and built building up and how
they're going to get in back I love how
Cisco just knows how to invent something
to get the flash to come back is always
a solution for something I like seeing
the ramifications as when you get stuck
in the Speed Force at the end or rather
when he goes off with his mother there
it's interesting to see the dramatic
tension that's going on with iris like
your father's asked me are you alright
like that whatever you want me to say
like I like seeing that those moments
like it's interesting to see how the
team is doing about Barry because and I
like what you said I'm glad they didn't
show Barry because one of the biggest
issues I have as I mentioned kind of
earlier with season 3 they kind of went
into flashpoint paradox only did like a
a episode or so yeah I want to see a
couple episodes of Barry trapped in the
Speed Force rather so that's why I'm
looking forward to give us a couple
episodes where he's gone and stuck there
I guess it's making me wonder if the
first episode because I imagine that
Barry will definitely be back for most
of the second episode of least it seems
like a trailer mainly for the first
episode and I'm wondering if they'll
show Barry at all throughout the first
episode of really only coming at the end
of the first episode and the whole time
we'll just be focusing on the cast and
what they've been up to how they've been
functioning without Barry you know I
said I really care about iris has cared
for the first couple seasons but I
didn't learn to care about her a lot
more in the third season maybe because
her life was at stake the entire time
I'm also wondering what's going on with
Caitlin snow she left the group and then
she comes back with like Captain colds
gun or something but you were telling me
before hand about the the series villain
this year I don't think that was in that
samurai go away so I'm not sure that
character usually don't introduce the
newest villain up front yeah but I mean
from again the clues we got from season
3 they mentioned Clifford DeVoe a few
times even Sabbat are mentioned Clifford
avoids like oh you haven't met him yet
Clifford devote he's actually the
thinker another thinker he was the first
time we saw him in the comics was in all
flashy number 12 years created by II his
and Gardner Fox and what's interesting
about this character he's a failed
lawyer and he encounters a lot of
villains and what's cool about him is he
realizes these loans have the skill to
do the job they just don't have to
intellect they don't have the brains to
do this and he takes it upon himself to
become the brains of the the crime
underworld and he battles flash many
times and what I like about this
character and also to one other thing to
know he's really into new scientific
technology there's something called that
he used called the thinking cap it's a
metal hat puts on and it projects mental
force so that's going to be really
interesting to see visually as well as
compelling and the storyline as well see
how they introduced the thinking cap but
what I love that about Barry not going
up against the speedster it makes him
more interesting that he's going up
against someone who doesn't have to bow
in physically battle him intellectually
so that's what I'm really looking
forward to Moses season on top of the
dramatic tension we see from the group
dealing with Perry being gone you know
the Speed Force I'm really looking
forward to seeing Perry go up against
someone that's not a speeds here because
obviously you bar Thon's my favorite
villain of all time I'm just looking
forward to seeing him go up against
someone you know kind of goes against
them in an intellectual way just I find
that very compelling when I see that
like mission impossible 5 you didn't
have to physically beat that guy but
that guy was beating him mentally and
intellectually and I find that very
compelling in stores when when told the
right way why just stole my point
sorry Greg what were you going to say
just stole my point that was like
everything I told you before we started
filming thanks for doing that Andrew I
stole this information from Greg stole
it from the future every sweet librarian
I know very future and I'm going to use
it again I hear it and I be really well
yeah I mean I refined it for it I'll
finally be able to start watching this
show when the episodes are airing as
opposed to Netflix binging it that way
so it comes back baby and I'm wondering
which Harrison wells version we're going
to be getting wonder if tom Felton will
return well guys there's a reaction
review for the flash I'm glad I got to
provide most of the information on this
video you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell and
here's a movie source channel what
information that you think those guys go
over there check it out and he also is a
Gore 7-eleven on Twitter and Instagram
go check out our patron offer exclusive
person rewards
right Barry